I found something you gotta check this
out you plays for games anymore
yo what's this
[Applause]
Jumanji pick a character and you're that
person in the game Bethany you went I
don't spend my life staring at a TV
screen it's my hair
whose dress to me
oh my god varying different people's
party
Stephanie don't look at it I'm an
overweight middle-aged man wait a second
where's my phone don't cry don't cry
don't cry
I think we've become the avatars we
charge welcome to Jumanji this is a
video game which means reach f3 lives
let's go I'm Alex watch your step in
here so gnarly we can help each other we
all have special skills weakness I hate
this game everybody else got good stuff
weakness Hey
yes cake is my weakness look at what is
Valley what is that I think it means you
carry my weapons and give them to me
when I tell you to don't let this new
body get your butt wolf we have to work
together
you think it's a staring contest who's
good at staring and not blinking - I'm
amazing at it I like this place
[Music]
we get on my back
no no I'll carry you come on I would
rather die get on my back nope I'm going
down
[Music]
boom cake cake isn't that your weakness
something happening to me am i shaking
I'm not still black yes okay everything
is fine it's all good
[Applause]
[Music]
you